quand on fait route au nord-ouest en
quittant granville on trouve à 12 milles
environ
le premier maillon de cette chaîne de
rochers et d'îles dont la plus connue
est jersey ce premier maillon le seul
qui soit encore français ces choses est
dans ses parages les épaves ne sont pas
rares et on le comprend quand on défile
devant ces récifs ils sont trois cent
soixante-cinq autant que de jours dans
l'année qui truffent la mer aux abords
de chausey rênes de cet archipel la
plupart du temps enfouie sous l'eau
passait le barrage de ces dangereux
caillou le petit port présente un aspect
plus riant
à mi-mars et chose y'a et touristes
doivent se livrer à quelques acrobaties
pour toucher terre
il leur reste alors à monter la cale
toujours encombrée de casiers à homards
car les pêcheurs de l'île et ceux de
granville fournissent à la france plus
de 80% de ces crustacés
voici 23 ans ils se sont durement
accroché avec les anglais sur les fameux
banc nous en reparlerons
le phare qui sont rarement de la brume
mais le point le plus élevé de l'île de
son sommet l'on découvre les abords à
l'équinoxe de septembre il se
métamorphose totalement l'espace d'une
marée d'une mère presque lisse surgi ce
paysage lunaire
quand nous tirons dans six heures 20
mètres dos le plus fort étiage du monde
entier
abbas mère la petite ans de blainville
est d'un dessin si pure est à sec
c'est là qu'habite la plupart des
pêcheurs
parmi eux une femme du chambre et je pas
que vous êtes le seul marin femmes de
l'île chose c'est un métier assez durs
pour une femme qu'est ce que vous faites
exactement bien mon dieu abord je
m'occupais qui travaillent de pêche
évidemment je m'occupe aussi des hommes
qui était un petit confort et puis tout
simplement pas tant du point de vue des
cheveux points de passage et il était
alors les passagers l'été et la plongée
divers et vous êtes toujours sur le
bateau si toujours sur mon gâteau grâce
à l'autorisation du mari pourquoi ce
spécial c'est très spécial je crois que
nous sommes trois en france c'est tout
bon je pense que pour faire un métier
pareil vous êtes né dans cet archipel
vous êtes vraiment de du coin je ne suis
pas mis dans cet archipel n'ont su ni un
internaute et rambouillet fichtre qu'est
ce que j'ai lu ni ferry j ai bien bougé
depuis 20 ans ça donne il d'ailleurs
c'est pourquoi je construise neigé aussi
à la construire avec nous serons
pression ici parce que c'est très
délicat
et puis en plus j'adore la mer j'ai
toujours aimé la mer 6 sur 10 la mère
elle est présente à chausey par tout son
sens ce vallon qu'on appelle la ferme
ici le sol fertile et on y rencontre eux
mêmes un troupeau de vaches mais qu'ils
étaient trois ce vallon on en sort à
peine qu'on tombe sur la maison du
commandant plessis la vie l'homme dont
l'action failli voici 23 ans à propos de
la pêche au homard provoquer un drame
on m'a dit dans le pays que personne lui
vous ne pouvez me raconter la fameuse
querelle entre les anglais les français
au sujet des mains qui est est ce que
c'est vrai j'ai participé à l'expédition
qu elle explique j'ai été un peu à cause
en trente neuf quand on a construit
cette campagne cet abri pour les
pêcheurs alors ça s'est passé comment eh
bien ça s'est passé de la façon suivante
c'est que
les anglais n'est ce pas commencer avait
balisé un peu partout et de plus en plus
ils mettaient la main sur des minquiers
puisqu'il mettait des affiches où il y
avait et à jersey mathier le conflit
s'ils ont pu dire existe depuis bientôt
des centenaires voyez vous bon alors
vous êtes allés au minquiers avec une
équipe de gars oui de pêcheurs en vue
les choses
et qu'est ce que vous avez fait là bas
eh bien nous avons monté une un abri
pour les pêcheurs pour qu'ils puissent
se réfugiant comme mauvais temps et nous
avions la pharmacie couchage chauffage
les drapeaux français bien entendu
rapace a indiscutablement puisque les
anglais ont toujours eu un drapeau les
tennismen et en en ferait pour le mettre
en place
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé les
anglais ont pris la mouche alors il
s'est passé ce c7 nous avons construit
cette cabane ça a été fait d'ailleurs en
36 heures
oui un avion de
cherbourg est venu nous donner l'eau
d'arrêter les travaux mais comme les
travaux ont été faits on s'en est foutu
naturellement et alors on est reparti on
a laissé la place propre et quand les
anglais sont venus bas ma foi ils ont
constaté que tout était construit et
combien vu une photo du président de la
république ça les a refroidis n'en
posent et c'est elle touche à la cabane
c'était président le mandat
mais un procès après alors soit on
laisse entraîner dans beaucoup plus loin
les anglais sont en je crois d'ailleurs
qu'en france on a voulu aussi faire
trancher là dans la cour de la haye oui
on a perdu je crois et on a perdu alors
le plateau des minquiers et maintenant
des pendaisons et anglais seulement
comme on en a je crois que les pêcheurs
disent qu'ils ont quand même le droit
d'aller y pêcher il ya une convention de
pêche de signer avant la décision de la
cour de l'est qui donnait aux pêcheurs
de là où notre pays le droit de renvoyer
dans les matières
elle est toujours valable elle est
toujours valable alors en somme ça peut
aller en ce sens va tourner ou java y'a
pas tout
ainsi parla le commandant plessis
décidément la guerre du homard n'est pas
pour demain et c'est tant mieux pour
tout le monde et d'abord pour les choses
y ait ces pêcheurs de chausey nous en
avons trouvé plusieurs familles dans ce
vieux fort vauban en en traçant les
plans n'imaginais pas qu'un jour l'âge
des insulaires qui flotterait à tous les
vents de la rose le confort y est
relatif chose l hiver est souvent coupée
du continent ce passe de pain et comme
lille n'a pas d'eau potable en bois de
l'evian on en boit d'ailleurs très peu
mais en raison même de cet isolement en
eut lieu de france n'existe une pareille
densité d'antenne de télévision
à 300 mètres du vieux fort l'église qui
voisine avec l'école
la cure est à côté je tuerai on m'a dit
que par exemple tout à l'heure je suis
passé devant la petite école et dans le
pays on m'a dit j'ai demandé qui était
l'instituteur on m'a dit mais c'est
monsieur le curé c'est vrai mais c'est
tout ce qu'il ya de plus vrai et il faut
considérer que c'est une école publique
mais je n'appartiens pas à l'éducation
nationale c'est plutôt une école
municipale
alors je suis agréé par le maire comme
instituteur et en même temps pour
m'occuper des différentes paperasse de
mairie qui peuvent avoir lieu sur chose
est alors en somme ça vous fait déjà en
dehors de votre sacerdoce bien entendu
j'ai vu votre église et les très jolies
en dehors de votre sacerdoce vous êtes
aussi il est aussi instituteur vous et
vous expédier le ce que vous appelez la
paperasse municipal bien que ce soit pas
je crois une mairie qui ne s'est pas de
municipalités chose ans et on m'a dit
aussi que votre charité s'étendait à
autre chose que vous vous occupiez des
malades par exemple assurément
maintenant dans ce domaine là il ne
faudrait pas me donner le titre de
médecin car je ne suis jamais qu'à un
modeste infirmiers enfin on fait ce
qu'on peut et on essaie de dépanner le
monde quand c'est possible car y'a pas
de médecin dans l' il n'y a pas de
médecins dans l'île et quand il ya des
cas un peu sérieux alors on transporte
les malades à granville et monsieur le
curé vous avez un bateau naturellement
vous êtes pêcheurs ou x a sûrement bien
je suis pêcheur quand j'en aime loisirs
ça me plaît beaucoup mais il faut
pouvoir le faire en suspens il paraît
que vous réparez les bateaux par le
moteur est en panne en paca ya quelque
chose qui ne va pas c'est exact aussi
m'enfin je ne fais jamais que quelques
petits bricolages pour rendre service
aux uns et aux autres surtout quand ça
les empêche pas vraiment de faire leurs
marais ce serait vraiment dommage qu'ils
perdent leur journée et ne gagne pas le
re up seul et combien de pas de
paroissiens bien il faut en compter 125
125e des brèches louzier sédentaires
sédentaires oui maintenant l'hiver ça
tombe tout de même à une soixantaine
vont les autres
les autres seront à granville parce que
ici ne pourrait pas gagner leur vie
l'hiver ce qui leur fait gagner leur vie
en somme c'est le hummer et l'hiver
il y en a pour ainsi dire pas je vous
posais une dernière question je précise
que la peine de vous la posez d'ailleurs
est ce que vous êtes attachés aux îles
chausey
c'est une question en effet qui est tout
à fait superflue
si je suis venu à changé c'est justement
parce que je me suis trouvé fasciné par
chose et est en effet c'est une
situation très attachante et j'irai même
jusqu'à plaisanté en disant en disant
qu'elle est encore plus attachantes les
jours ne peut pas en sortir quand on ne
peut pas en sortir plus de touristes les
gens du pays seulement parmi laquelle
louis renault venait se détendre vous
venez de voir sa demeure elle est sur la
côte ouest
plus sauvage encore que l'autre avec ses
roches bizarre ces épaves et c'est
pêcheuse de beaumont
il faut voir ces grèves à marée basse au
soir tombant quand un chien mélancolique
air parmi les flaques
il a raison le curé de chausey